я дякую комісії за роботу але мені би
дуже хотілося щоб це не обмежилось лише
констатацією фактів А щоби нарешті винні
були притягнуті до відповідальності
практика На жаль показує як тільки винні
у розкраданні належать до військових
адміністрацій або наближені до влади все
це Тихенько замовчується в марафонах
цієї інформації не подається а в
результаті ми маємо сотні тисяч сотні
мільйонів гривень розкрадання і ми маємо
тисячі тонн продуктів які просто
позагнили на складах військових
адміністрацій я нагадаю це Чернігів у
складі площею 1000 метрів квадратних
згнили продукти в той час коли люди
голодували Запоріжжя розкрадено
гуманітарки 389 вагонів 220 вантажівок
22 контейнери
322 млн грн приблизно розкладання коштів
і все тихенько бо там це все покриває
голова адміністрації Київ Сотні тонн
згнили в продуктів знищеної амуніції яка
була це потрібна на фронті але її поїли
миші бо комусь хотілося це все заникати
а потім Можливо перепродати я вже мовчу
як окремі представники від влади
роздають агітаційні кульочки з власної
символікою а всередині лежать прод
набори передані як гуманітарна допомога
але в той же час тривають переслідування
волонтерів ви думаєте хоч Одна справа
була закрита ні жодна на сучасний етап
ми маємо понад 130 вилучених у
волонтерів автомобілів куплених за
зібрані кошти і вже кілька місяців
автомобілів стоять на складах а окремі
структури пробують торгуватися і кажуть
віддайте Ці автомобілі нашим
поліцейським зокрема структурам а тоді
ми можливо вам решту віддамо це є маразм
і цініст і це довіри зараз до держави на
жаль нема Я бажаю комісії зробити хоча
би перші кроки до встановлення
справедливості